Look At This Candle The Base Of The Candle Looks Something Like This This Shape
Is
Called A Cylinder Observe The Shape Carefully It Has One
Curved Surface And Two Equal Plain Circles One
On Top And One At The Bottom If We Remove The
Plain Circles The Cylinder Will  Look Something
Like This What Remains Is Just The Curved
Surface Now Let's Do Something In Resting We Try To
Cut Open This Curved Surface
Vertically When The Curved Surface Is Cut Open It Will
Look Something Like This And What Will Happen If We
Open This Up Further Look  We Get a
Rectangle This
concept is very important and will
help you in understanding the concept of
surface area So how do we define a
cylinder Let's zoom out a bit and draw the
cylinder There are just two things that we use
to define a cylinder first its  Height and
Second The Radius of the Plane Circles
Remember These Two Circles Are Equal in Size
So the Radii of Both Circles Are Equal Some
Times Even Two Things Are Enough to Define
Three Dimension Shapes and Some Times Even One
Parameter Is Enough to Define Them This
Is a Football and It Has Just One Curved
Surface This
Three Dimension Figure Can Be Drawn Like This This
Dotted Potion Is the Part of the
Figure We Can't See from the Front and It
is Defined Just by Its Radius This
Radius Remains Constant from the Center  To
every point on the surface This point The center
is equidistant from every single point
on the curved surface And notice that this figure
has no vertices and no edges Such three figures a
called sphere And yes it is defined only by its
[Music]
radius